this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by blue apron blue aprons
great you understand me
I'm Krista Lee and I'm telling you this
for less than $10 a person per meal blue
apron delivers seasonal recipes along
with pre-portioned ingredients to make
delicious home-cooked meals you don't
have to think about it it just shows up
at your door and then you make this food
and you got to choose from a variety of
new recipes each week and they set it up
for you let blue aprons culinary team
surprise you even you could do that
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals free with free
shipping by going to blue apron com /
Congrats
you understand me welcome to
congratulations this is the podcast this
is how we're doing it okay and this is
like the 16th episode I think I have no
idea I literally have no idea until I'm
done with it
my producers not here it's just me we're
seeing if I could roll dough low dude
I'm on my dollar what the [ __ ] I'm on my
doll oh I don't even know if that means
by myself but I know Ice Cube says it so
I'm on my doll oh um but yeah so I'm by
myself you know what that means I'm in a
podcast room no completely naked and I
don't give a [ __ ]
I wanted to always feel what it's like
to do my art and speak my mind
to a bunch of people thousands of people
let my balls just air out and that's how
it's going to be it's actually a little
more air echoey because of my my
producers not here any D brings a bunny
always brings a bunch of fat cats with
him and he lies them around so it eats
up the sound it brings about fifteen to
sixteen fat cats and sets them all up
and I'm naked I'm completely naked
and that's what's up dude this is the
naked podcast congratulations the naked
podcast so I am in Los Angeles and I've
been in Los Angeles for a week and you
know I've been doing this movie I shot
the movie for about three weeks and then
I was back in LA and I'm wrapping up my
time in LA now because I'm going back to
Toronto to do the movie to finish up the
movie and I have enjoyed being in Los
Angeles I caught up with some people I
got to see my mom for my Mother's Day or
as she said it calls it Mother's Day I
don't know why she does that she does
that because she likes to just be silly
and weird but um yeah so I did that and
and now I'm going back to Toronto um and
I'm I feel like I where's the deal I
went up last night I did some stand-up
at The Comedy Store in the Laugh Factory
and it felt good man it felt really good
to be back home and doing doing stand-up
and doing jokes and a lot of this stuff
was newer stuff and it was very cool
because some of the people there hadn't
seen me in about three or four weeks and
some of the door guys were like hey you
know like the new stuff kept me charged
man it made me realize I'm a comedian
you know even though I've been doing
this this drama in Toronto it made me
realize that at my heart comedian so
thanks for uh thanks for letting me do
that world and so uh now I'm I'm I'm
chillin they asked me when I wanted to
go back to Toronto they gave me an early
flight or a late flight option asked for
the late flight and they said never mind
they're going to give me their early
flight so I said okay you know because
I'm not going to argue with production I
went to this nice place for Mother's Day
or for Mother's Day as my mom would call
it for fun and it was a fish place and
they had the the jackasses if you're a
grown man and you're eating crab you
don't [ __ ] put a bib on do you
understand me that's for a six-year-old
you grown man I saw this grown man that
was just eaten
crab and had the bib on like he was a
[ __ ] 8 year old but he was
40-something and you could tell by the
look on his face that he just wanted to
order the crab so he could be cute and
put the bib on makes it double doubly
bad if you really want crab you're like
I want crab and they're like no what I
really don't actually want to mess up my
suit then fine that's bad enough just be
good
get the [ __ ] on your suit or [ __ ] be
careful you get an adult but that's it
man if you're not if you're not if
you're not if you if if you're like me
look at the crab maybe I'll get them
[ __ ] you know salmon but you like ah
but I'll wear the babe it would be
really fun I'll be the funny guy at the
table with the bib on and I'll do bib
jokes Yee kuda and you know it dude
because you seen something and you need
distraction um yeah don't do that I
don't know what I don't know um I don't
know don't do that that's my PSA for now
the first you got to start off sort of
hot that's my hot [ __ ] right there so
the new hotness when I saw men in black
the trailer and when he said and when
Will Smith said old and crusty or he
said old and busted new hotness and
appointed to his current set new hotness
I was like I love Will Smith from now on
I mean I already love them but that [ __ ]
[ __ ] new hotness you're 40 and you
say new hotness I just why you lessen
younger than dude how about when okay
I'm 37 now and I watch back these movies
that I loved and I was like oh man let's
watch a movie Will Smith what's an old
Will Smith will be any watching an old
Will Smith movie and he was [ __ ] and
you're and you expect him to be like 45
because you're you were younger and he
was a grown man but really Will Smith is
like [ __ ] seven years older than me
he's not 50 right dude that's insane to
me to look at men in black and be like
oh he was 19 oh he was 14 than that
oh oh Will Smith did men in black when
he was 11
drinking Lacroix if you're a [ __ ]
or you can say Lacroix
I want every up by the way I don't like
that like any kind of like croissant
like its croissant if you're in America
its croissant it's not quite all because
every thing in every language should
have its other language version right
like burrito in you know Spanish is now
burrito if you're [ __ ] order and you
say burrito as an American you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] get the bib eat that
burrito you know but there should be
something like that my dad said
something to me like yeah you're a real
I can't remember the my camera the word
but it was an O is a word that it was an
Italian every now and then my dad is s
satalia n-- like all of a sudden he's a
gentleman children lie but at the waiter
made the world thinly and you're like uh
but he used that Italian word and I said
what the hell does that mean he's like
there's not a word for it in English it
means one who simply doesn't give a [ __ ]
I'm like well just then don't use that
word I wish I remember what it was but I
don't remember um so he did that and I
invited him to get a booty go and drink
some Lacroix like why look boy back lay
like Claire um so yeah don't don't have
the bib and also you know but I don't
know everyone always thinks are [ __ ]
extra and cool and fun and I like to
think about you know what's funny to me
is like when people like the big guy if
you take a guy who's like the babe but
the big the big guy I don't I took me 40
tries to say that but the big guy at the
restaurant they look at me look at me
guy or the guy who walks in I saw a guy
walk into the coffee shop yesterday or
one of these days recently I don't know
I need to tell you guys the truth about
that but it was one of these days
not yesterday I don't think and he
walked in and you can tell he was
filling himself like he was murdering
just walking in right like he thought he
felt like maybe I maybe I'm on The
Truman Show just just in case I'm on The
Truman Show and everybody in the world's
watching I'm gonna blast through this
door like I'm John goddamn Wayne and so
he walked through the door and you could
tell he was fooling himself because his
eyes were a little bit a little bit
squinty ER lentil bit squinty ER or
little bit squinty ER I think I meant
little bit squinty ER because a lentil
bit squid tear is not words are not
words so he walked in and he was killing
it a little bit and immediately when I
think it when I see a somebody who does
that that thinks they're all that or
killing it or [ __ ] you know if they
got a cool oh by the way i you know i
also saw recently there was a few
episodes ago maybe actually was like the
third or fourth episode I saw a guy I
was making fun of the guy who was
wearing the cool dope [ __ ] and his name
was still Brad at the coffee shop like
you can't wear the dopest [ __ ] if and
then he still has to say his name is
Brad or whatever the name was um so I
always like to imagine those guys as
dope as they are as cool as they can
possibly be I like to imagine them dead
asleep because to me that's hilarious
no matter how dope you are no matter how
[ __ ] ill your collar is or how
[ __ ] shiny those boots are or roughed
up those jeans are in the most perfect
way or how cool you think you are and
charismatic you think you are when
you're talking to a lady you still
[ __ ] sometimes sleep like a baby and
that's so funny to me to be like yeah
I'm the [ __ ] but then imagining that guy
all curled up like a cute [ __ ]
just like and then waking up just like
you little [ __ ] ah you little [ __ ]
[ __ ] you still have to sleep a lot
that's so funny to me I could imagine
myself one day in my old age getting mad
like at somebody that thinks he's cool
like super dope and just being like [ __ ]
you you sleep you still [ __ ] sleep
sometimes like a baby and have him
having no idea what the [ __ ] I mean but
I know what I mean
that's nirvana I think I legitimately
think that's nirvana
is when you're saying [ __ ] like that
whatever the Italian [ __ ] word is oh
[ __ ] is that Italian word I'm gonna text
my dad right now he won't get back to me
until tomorrow cuz he's [ __ ] 70 um
hey Dad what was that word Italian watch
I might say hey Dad what was that
Italian word and he's gonna be like what
Italian word you gotta be real specific
with people as they get older you can't
be like like you could say hey hand me
that thing to a 25 year old and they
know exactly what you're talking about
you say hand me that thing to a [ __ ]
75 year old the literal they'll look at
you like it's the last question on
[ __ ] Jeopardy look I I didn't study
like that's how they look at you
you'd be like the [ __ ] thing we were
talking about for the past 20 minutes
with the scissors like we should have
said for considers um yeah whatever
whatever it was though how cool
oh it's really cool to that I have to
[ __ ] networks in my house for some
reason so it never works when I [ __ ]
doesn't the one the one I like to use
Siri voice text the one that doesn't
give a [ __ ]
that's so not good English but easy so
he's not gonna know what I mean but
anyway um so yeah uh-oh I I don't
remember what I was talking to I bet
base here worst house host ever
worst [ __ ] host ever you know what
honestly uh oh yeah sleeping like a baby
like sleeping like a [ __ ] baby dude
it's it's funny to me I used to think
about like how no matter how funny how
[ __ ] dope someone wasn't like they
trip but like tripping isn't as good as
sleeping like we have to sleep like
that's like we no matter how cool we are
no matter how dope we are we still
[ __ ] are number one something we need
to do is sleep nobody's better than that
that's the best to me we're all [ __ ]
cuz asleep all [ __ ] because asleep
speaking of bad hosts and
and this is actually not fair because I
don't think he's a bad host I think he's
a great host but did you hear but
speaking of hosts period Louis I sleep
speaking of hosts did anybody see I kind
of missed this I got late in the game
here I didn't know about it the day it
happened when it was blowing up but this
email that Steve Harvey sent out to his
to his uh to his uh staff about how the
new rules for season five on his show
and and the internet is like lighting
them up for it and everyone's like this
guy should be fired this guy should be
uh replaced and they have like they're
trying to get like 50,000 signatures and
they already got like 25,000 signatures
to [ __ ] cancel his show and I did a
show get yeah I did can't they did
cancel it it says right here uh this is
from Robert Feder
Chicago media served fresh daily since
1980 Thursday marks the final day of
production for the Steve Harvey Show
after five years in Chicago after that
it's packing up and moving to Los
Angeles okay no it didn't get canceled
it's just moving to Los Angeles that's
the thing and everyone wants him to get
fired online because this is the best
I [ __ ] love Steve Harvey by the way
after this I'm a huge Steve Harvey fan I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't care
politically I don't care who you're for
I think he's for Trump I don't give a
[ __ ] you do you Steve Harvey we need
people in America that [ __ ] do them
you understand I just you know maybe
everybody should vote that's what I
think if we're talking politics but
we're not we're talking about personal
[ __ ] we're not talking about personal
[ __ ] we're talking about you in the
workplace you got to do you bro
sociopaths and Psychopaths [ __ ]
succeed because they're hyper focused
and I think Steve Harvey may be a
[ __ ] psychopath or sociopath
so here are the rules that he put out
for season five of his and any attack
and I have a lot of thoughts thoughts
about this okay
on this website it says uh
uh okay these were the things he said
good morning on an email good morning
everyone this is an email he sent to
everybody good morning everyone welcome
back good morning and welcome back so
starting really nice I'd like you all to
review and adhere to the following notes
and rules for season five of my talk
show now he came out with a [ __ ] bang
right like he was nice for two short
sentences and then he was like now
here's how it's going to go
[ __ ] that means that he
shouldn't even have been nice and the
first two sentence I don't like that I
got to say he should have either been
nice nicer for longer or just started
off what's up [ __ ] and then I'd
like you all to review and adhere to the
following notes and rules for season
five to my talk show now I think this is
how it should have been what's up
[ __ ] this is how it's going to
be from now on and I think instead of
all that should I just read this is the
end the words house going to be from now
on should all be one word that that
would be this is the only way that I
would be a bigger fan of Steve Harvey
after this email is if this he did it
like this what's up [ __ ] this
is house going to be from now on
one word okay and then this is back to
what he actually said there will be no
meetings in my dressing room no stopping
by or popping in no one loved that he
said stopping by or popping in because
he meant it he said the same thing twice
with different words and then he said in
caps no one so that means even the
people that thought that they were
closer than him then that other people
that were reading the email just read
that part and got extra like oh he means
me
it's like like he I love the fact that
Steve Harvey probably has a best friend
on the show and he still sent the email
to everybody and included the best
friend and that no one was particularly
for that best friend okay then he writes
do not come to my dressing room unless
invited now that's the same goddamn
thing he just said which is amazing okay
so far it's like somebody every episode
comes into so forth this email is
literally written like somebody comes
into his dressing room every shoot
and [ __ ] him up the ass and and and he
does not want it to happen and he cannot
stop it and and no matter what and and
as as he gets [ __ ] in the ass
he's like the guys like the guys saying
this [ __ ] in like French or whatever
[ __ ] word whatever language he's like
example but bad but bad and steep arse
like who the [ __ ] is his French guys say
and what's he saying he never knew what
he was saying he didn't know who he was
because he's hooded and then after
season four right before season five he
realized that in French the guy was
saying if you want this to stop all you
have to do is email everybody in your
staff about and I won't pop by the only
way you can make me not stop Popeyes if
you email me by the way I mean your
staff you don't know who I am
you really see what is there so then
this is what he says do not open my
dressing room door which is the same
goddamn thing
this [ __ ] had a traumatic in
instance happen a lot in his dressing
room
and then in caps if you open my door
expect to be removed removed like you're
a molar not like you're a person
couldn't love Steve Harvey more right
now okay then my security team will stop
everyone from standing at my door who
had the intent to see or speak to me or
[ __ ] me up the ass in parentheses French
guy that's for you just kidding it ended
with speak to me obviously but that's
how it because we know something was
going on then it says I want all the
ambushing to stop now now you know he's
been [ __ ] in the ass repeatedly in his
dressing room you know for sure that
he's been [ __ ] in the ass because he
would use the word ambush like he kind
of like showed his hand right there and
he writes that includes steep that
includes TV staff now right there he
thinks that the French guy is a TV like
there's some French people and his
friend his TV staff and he thinks that
maybe some of those guys are the guys
that [ __ ] him up the ass then he writes
you must schedule an appointment now
that means maybe he would like to get
[ __ ] in the ass but he doesn't want to
be taken by surprise while he's getting
[ __ ] in
right he wants to at least know what's
coming so he can do some calisthenics
first okay then here we go here we go
this is the part that the thing that
really [ __ ] takes it to the next
level and to where we know that
something went down I have been taken
advantage of by my lenient policy in the
past this ends now no more in caps
nobody says no more in caps
unless you've sincerely been and I mean
this taken advantage of sexually nobody
says no more in caps like that nobody
types that unless somebody's been taking
a sexually advantage of here's another
it keeps going do not approach me while
I'm in the makeup chair unless I asked
to speak with you directly either knock
or use the doorbell my favorite thing
about that is why is there a goddamn
doorbell in the makeup trailer it's a
makeup trailer where you only get makeup
done by the way I don't know a lot of
people I don't know how it works a
makeup trailer is legitimately just used
for getting your makeup done
there is no reason there should be a
doorbell on it and that's why Steve
Harvey is my number one favorite person
at this point in this email okay this is
the best part right here I'm not the
best but I'm sorry it just keeps getting
better is what I mean next he says I
promise you I will not entertain you in
the hallway that's like that's funny to
think like I'm an entertainer and I'll
[ __ ] entertain people on the show but
don't you [ __ ] think I'm gonna be tap
dancing [ __ ] in the hallway hey
this is the best man this is so specific
I love it I promise you I will not
entertain you in the hallway and do not
attempt to walk with me this dude wants
to [ __ ] roll on his dole oh dude this
is now this is another part that [ __ ]
hits the friends hits his friends if
you're reading this yes I mean you
so what guess what that means that means
me to me Chris D'Elia me I'm not on this
show but I read
so he means me I like that the email is
personal to me now and then he writes a
little bit trust to realize maybe you
got a little hot so he writes everyone
do not take offense to the new way of
doing business it is for the good of my
personal life and now that's fine
but then this part is the really
[ __ ] he writes end enjoyment it
is for the good of my personal life and
enjoyment mean take the person life out
of it it is for my enjoyment oh hey
don't walk with me don't pop in my room
ring the doorbell on my makeup trailer
do not [ __ ] come up to me in the
hallway because because and and and I
want you to know that you can't do this
because it's for my enjoyment that's
amazing that's an evil villain that's
the king that went bad and decided to
ruin the nation or whatever the [ __ ] you
rule over it's awesome dude that's
amazing now not talk about not giving a
[ __ ] one who doesn't give a [ __ ] my dad
texted me back mana fridge ista mana
frige ista one who does not give a [ __ ]
Steve Harvey and people are like he
should be fired he should be fired [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that he's the boss he's the
boss it's his show you can't do the show
without him they're gonna throw the
[ __ ] show off the air [ __ ] that don't
work for him I understand everybody like
relies on us my job now I gotta work
[ __ ] that have fun you know what dude if
somebody said that to me if somebody had
those rules to me I couldn't help myself
I'd have to [ __ ] pop hey what's up
Steve in the hallway what's going on man
he'd be like did you read my [ __ ]
email or he wouldn't even entertain me
he imeem [ __ ] that he's my hero in
business we need more [ __ ] like
that that's awesome it's my favorite
literally that's my favorite email I've
ever read no doubt No
out I just like thinking about how some
French guy definitely [ __ ] him in the
ass and that's why he wrote that email I
mean that's just but but the amount of
flack he got on it on the internet for
that is just so stupid it's so stupid to
go after somebody like that it's fine to
make a joke like you know if comedians
are like whoa Steve Harvey is a [ __ ]
diva and [ __ ] making jokes about it
you know but come on dude
really oh he's a piece of [ __ ] that
that's how we got it that's let me tell
you something to a person like that is
either miserable or the happiest
[ __ ] I was I mean I saw somebody
the other day that was talking about uh
you know she was insane and she was she
kept on repeating herself like hey if
she said if you need a new costume
designer if you need a new costume
designer yeah there's a costume you know
I'll get your costumes all set up just
talking to nobody
nobody she was talking to nobody at a
cafe and she was happy no she had mental
problems of course because she wasn't a
costume designer and because she wasn't
looking at anybody talking she was
pretending like she was talking to
people that weren't there or just kind
of to the room but that's like a step or
two away from what Steve Harvey Harvey
Steve Harvey is a step or two away from
that but those people are happy some
some crazy [ __ ] are happy as
[ __ ] dude you see him laughing you see
me you see them laughing and drooling
and picking their nose in public without
a care in the world
god bless metaphors ISTA live it up my
babies manna frig [ __ ] ji stead dude
metaphor
I'm doing this [ __ ] podcast naked his
[ __ ] man afford ISTA you feel me ah you
know what I mean boy
blue apron is the number one fresh
ingredient in recipe delivery service in
the country in the country we want to
miss out on that know its mission is to
make incredible home cooking accessible
to everyone alright it's as more
sustainable food system it sets high
standard the highest standards for
ingredients and it builds a community of
home chefs all right you can get the
food yourself it's it's it's also it's
it's it's partnered with over 150 local
farms fisheries and ranchers across the
United States all right seafood is good
it's developed there under standard is
developed in partnership with the
Monterey Bay Aquarium Seafood Watch the
beef and chicken and pork come from
responsibility raised animals you know
you can and you it's affordable also you
might be like well that must cost 14
thousand dollars a month but it doesn't
it's not for it's not for somebody who's
loaded who's got boats you can get it
for less than $10 per person per meal
blue apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre proportioned ingredients
to make delicious home-cooked meals all
right it's got a variety and it's
flexible to can customize your recipes
each week based on your preferences
several delivery options choose what
fits your needs and there's no
commitment weekly so you can get
deliveries when you want them it's easy
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals free with free
shipping go to blue apron calm slash
Congrats just hit that blue apron calm
slash Congrats you'll love how good it
feels
and taste to create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron don't
wait go to blue apron dot-com / Congrats
blue apron a better way to cook I always
wanted to be one of those guys that like
had a that did a voiceover for like some
[ __ ] company and did a tagline and at
the end of the tagline
you talk like this Hyundai it's got four
wheels and feels amazing Hyundai I'm so
bad by the way at hearing people's
voices when I know who they are I know
it's somebody but I don't know who you
know but it's like just a voiceover and
and it's like a Hyundai commercial or
something like who is that and then I
have no idea and I don't want to Google
it because that's cheating and then
seven weeks later I just go like this
James Spader and I figure out who it is
walking down the streets of Toronto and
people think I have Tourette syndrome
and my tick is screaming out James
Spader Manaf rejoice the babies you got
to get to that point in your life you're
happier I think to a point and then you
get to the point where you're like
[ __ ] insane and then you you know you
maybe go down hit down the hill the
other way this guy uh sent me the most
powerful DM I ever got uh let me see if
I can find it
boy I have no [ __ ] idea am I gonna
find this I don't know if I'll find it
but come on [ __ ] okay I'll just
uh say it say what he said he said hey
man hey man um I yo you like cutting off
people on the road huh on Hollywood
Boulevard or whatever that was me you
cut off in the white Prius amazing dude
amazing that first of all I honestly
don't think it was me it I guess it
could have been but whatever together
then get that mad and then direct
message somebody for it is just the
[ __ ] most hilarious thing what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I want it to screenshot
and put it up but I can't find it now I
get [ __ ] too many mm so popular
you know but how funny is that that he
did that that's some gangster [ __ ]
social media gangster [ __ ] I got a
release date for my uh my special by the
way it's January January [ __ ] idiot
yeah it's in 17 months it's it's June
June 27th June 27th man on fire
Netflix only on Netflix that's my new
special coming out so geek out if you're
a fan if you're not watch it anyway it's
a little bit more grown-up than my last
ship just trying to grow as an artist
man I hate when people say that but it
is kind of true you do have to do that
can't keep doing the same thing over and
over again because then you know it's
like what the [ __ ] you know dude work
out of your comfort zone I guess right
try try that's what it is really is try
just try don't be complacent I think so
it's definitely more of a point pull
more point-of-view driven more more it's
definitely still silly but it's I tell
more stories about what's going on in my
life I'm really proud of it to be honest
um and and so I'm excited for it to come
out I don't know though man everyone's
getting specials nowadays it's I feel
like specials aren't even special
anymore you just got to keep coming out
with them and you got to be more and
more prevalent with them I don't know
because you got to got to keep reminding
people that's what Bill burr was saying
I mean you got to keep reminding people
that you're out there until they just
[ __ ] can't ignore it because he does
especially once every like a year and a
half and I'm on like once every year or
and a half or two year and a half or two
years and but you know it helps also
doing movies you do a movie that comes
out you're in a TV show that comes out
you're gonna [ __ ] um yeah you got a
[ __ ] podcast you know you gotta be in
these [ __ ] face especially cuz
they could do anything they want to now
you could do anything you want to you
could you could you don't have to watch
a movie you could just look at your
phone and stay on Twitter nobody goes to
see the movie I mean remember when
movies like King Arthur
would [ __ ] murder in the box office
nobody went to go see that move across a
hundred and seventy five million dollars
to make opening weekend it made fourteen
million dollars it's a shame too it's
probably [ __ ] cool and good and
Charlie Hunnam is [ __ ] awesome and Guy
Ritchie's this [ __ ] but I just knew
nobody was going to see that movie
because it's just [ __ ] they can do
anything else they can do anything else
they wait for it to come out on iTunes
or [ __ ] Netflix or Hulu or something
um yeah I don't know I don't know every
every it's so crazy all these streaming
services though man Netflix Hulu Amazon
YouTube read now [ __ ] they're getting
into original programming with that
aren't just YouTube stars um what else I
don't know it's like they're gonna have
a [ __ ] they're gonna have like hey
I'm gonna have it get a call from agent
hate Tinder's reaching out they want us
don't want to do some original
programming do you have any ideas for
[ __ ] tinder TV and I'll be like I'm
not [ __ ] doing a show with tinder and
then it'll be like the hottest [ __ ]
thing in three years and they'll be
rebranded and I would have missed the
boat that's what [ __ ] Breaking Bad
did to AMC
that's what [ __ ] uh always sunny did
to FX people didn't watch that [ __ ] FX
was the place you went to to watch like
Turner and hooch that it was just on at
3:30 p.m. and you're like I remember
this moving to watch the end half of it
with the commercials but now it's like
the [ __ ]
AMC same thing AMC would have [ __ ]
they used to have corny ass movies and
then Breaking Bad came along and Mad Men
and it was over over madman was so dope
Mad Men was so dope people started
dressing different you know dopa [ __ ] it
that'd be like if game of throne if
everyone was walking around in like fur
collars and long capes carrying around
[ __ ] plastic swords and everyone had
a beard and long hair because the game
of Thrones
I mean everyone bought skinny ties and
[ __ ] did their hair like a like an
[ __ ] wax Ken doll because a [ __ ]
Don Draper everybody thought they were
Don Draper I love that people thought
there was bad is Don Draper and Don
Draper's what's his name uh James huh
ham John ham I'm so annoying I couldn't
get his name Jon Hamm was uh his
handsome he [ __ ] a ten you know and then
you'd have like goofball [ __ ] 22 year
olds being like I'm on Don Draper I'm on
the Don Draper tip and they just like
work at a [ __ ] bar and you're like
bro just put on the t-shirt and [ __ ]
you don't need to do your hair like that
you're not Don drape you Don Draper or
you Steve you're Don Draper or you guy
named Steve that lives in [ __ ]
Minnesota and works at a bar he in an ad
agency no you're not I'm drinking this
[ __ ] Lacroix that's how it is babies
how it is my babies man a fridge eat
manna for jeez huh man affront Kista you
know what I mean
should we go to gaming the system or
what I can't believe I got too hard to
game the system is still one of my
funniest [ __ ] on my head one time did
I tell this story already I have no idea
if I told the story already on the
[ __ ] podcast or not
you never know since we were talking
about crazy people and on the way to
crazy like Steve Harvey um you never
know you really never know who's crazier
not like the lady the cafe was saying
[ __ ] costume stylist or uh whatever
she could have been a [ __ ] stylist I
don't know I don't think she was but she
could have been uh she wasn't because
she was crazy but um
uh what do you call it um [ __ ] where
where am I here what am I talking about
crazy oh yeah I used to go to this
coffee shop in the valley when I ran the
[ __ ] I ran cold water [ __ ] coffee
mean dude I [ __ ] ran it I know I
talked about this on the podcast if
you're a loyal listener you know what
I'm talking about I [ __ ] ran that
[ __ ] um there used to be a guy that
would go there and every time he would
come in I loved talking to him because
he was batshit insane in my eyes this
dude was the best crazy person he would
talk to me be like hey man what's going
on he just sit look at everybody and
smile and what's up you know forty to
maybe forty three and um I don't know
what he did but he was always like so
man you are not you're a comedian huh
you're an actor and I was like yeah
anybody that's what they say that's what
they're telling me so man what do you
got some projects coming up but like I
just doing you know on this was like
[ __ ] 10 years ago
so I wasn't like really hitting I wasn't
doing a lot of stuff back then and this
guy would be like yeah I got a I got a I
got a hedge fund I got I'm [ __ ] movie
I'm doing we're developing some stuff
I'm starting to [ __ ] a company that
that serves food and caters I mean just
all sorts of lies just you could have
been and I would listen to him and my
other buddies would be there and be like
why do you [ __ ] always call him over
it so annoying but I was just [ __ ] so
fun to hear what this guy had to say and
knew he was making it up in his mind and
and that fascinates me because he would
just be like I'm you know I got my buddy
I mentioned like shoes and he'd be like
yeah my buddy you [ __ ] he uh is the
co-creator of the airmax or some [ __ ]
and I'd be like this guy's lyin so he
but he would occasionally bring up this
thing where he was like trying to do
this thing with like animal rights or
something and to help animals and spread
awareness for some [ __ ] thing I don't
I was 10 years ago I don't remember it's
like 10 years ago
I really don't member but he I do
remember he was like yeah we're doing
this thing where we're trying to [ __ ]
this llama has traveled across country
and we're we're bringing this allama to
different places and and it's going to
be in LA the llamas going to be in LA
and I know I know Jamie Masada at the
Laugh Factory you must know him and I
was like yeah perform there all the time
Jim Jim himself is the owner of the
Laugh Factory one of my [ __ ] great
friends great guy and
and he was like yeah and Jaime's had it
set up to where k-rock is going to come
out and they're going to talk to do this
radio [ __ ] and we're gonna have this
llama there you should come by and I'm
like this guy I mean now he's so crazy
that he knows that I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm
a new uh like I could check this I
Jamie's a buddy of mine right like I
could I perform at the left right now
right now I can fact check this [ __ ] but
I don't because I'm like there's no
reason a fact check it because this
[ __ ] isn't gonna bring a llama
to the Laugh Factory and k-rock doesn't
know about it right but anyway one of
the [ __ ] funniest things that this
guy did was I don't really know what he
was doing but he was got you know those
guys that [ __ ] order like four or
five coffees and then put him in the
tray and then leave the [ __ ] coffee
place and you're like who the [ __ ] would
that was the guy that they voted here at
the short straw or was he a PA he's got
like frappuccinos and [ __ ] all piled on
so he's got like four coffees he's got
like two exactly got two trays of
coffees so eight coffees in four [ __ ]
cut in four like oh there's two trays
and then the four polls you know I'm
talking about and so he's got eight
total coffees seven or eight maybe one
of the horses is is open but he's got
both of his hands full he says hey man
you and I after talking says you and I
should be his a whole conversation with
the to trace the a coffees you and I
should [ __ ] hang out sometime man
we'll get a [ __ ] bite to eat or go
grab a drink or something and I'm all
for it so I said [ __ ] yeah man and at
and as he kicks the door open because he
can't use his hand this is the most this
[ __ ] moment I've ever seen in my life he
kicks the door open to leave the [ __ ]
to leave the joint and he looks at me
and it doesn't break eye contact with
the coffee's with the nine [ __ ]
coffees in hand and says to me as he
kicks his way out of the door at as he
kicked his way out of the coffee shop
strictly hetero and [ __ ] leaves bro I
stopped laughing
yesterday strictly he says strictly
hetero like don't worry like it was like
the no homo [ __ ]
people say like yo no homo like rappers
but this guy [ __ ] took the white
crazy version and was like this is mine
now strictly had a row see ya hey let's
hang out grab a bite to eat or something
strictly hetero and [ __ ] walked out
and kicked out he was the [ __ ] [ __ ] them
all
this dude was the [ __ ] metaphor jeast
a-- and this dude sleeps like a baby
sometimes that's [ __ ] goddamn
hilarious to me he walked out a coffee
bean like this [ __ ] I just said
strictly hetero with nine coffees in my
hand and kicked the door open like I'm
on like I'm in Sin City the movie I
murdered that convo and he sleeps like a
baby that's the best that's the [ __ ]
best [ __ ] oh oh oh and here's the whole
point of me telling the [ __ ] story
I can't believe it I forgot about this
part I show I I'm not making this up I'm
not making this up I show up to the
Laugh Factory one night sure is [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] llama outside dude
there is a llama outside and k-rock is
in a van covering the event and this
[ __ ] strictly hetero dude is there
with the llama with Jamie Masada and he
says what's up Chris and I said I
literally looked at him and said you're
not crazy
I said I thought you were out of your
[ __ ] mind you really brought a llama
to the Laugh Factory
he was like yeah man didn't miss a beat
wasn't offended that I thought it was
crazy was just happy as [ __ ] that guy I
want to be at that level dude that's the
level I want to be at right under the
[ __ ] right right above Steve Harvey
that's that's [ __ ] three days away
from super Steve Harvey if he's not
careful but that's Orpheus gift that's
where I want to be that duck I was just
so happy man and I'm having I'm happy
but that [ __ ]
strictly hetero that was just amazing
that that happened that whole [ __ ]
I'll never forget any of that [ __ ] yeah
but my poor my point is it just goes to
show you you never know if somebody's
[ __ ] crazy or not I mean unless
you're said you're like a [ __ ] you
went to school for it and you're a
doctor
but I didn't know I didn't know I know I
didn't know um here's another [ __ ]
story while I'm [ __ ] on it one time I
was on a flight to okay so there's JFK a
lot of you probably know this but
there's JFK and then there's Newark you
can fly into either one it's close and
it's basically you you can fly in I was
going to Manhattan JFK is in Manhattan
and Newark is in New Jersey but it's
close to Manhattan and there's also
LaGuardia but I don't know where the
[ __ ] that is but that that's not in this
story it's close enough though so I was
flying into JFK now I'm in I'm in the UH
I'm in the first seat okay
of the plane and I'm not I'm saying this
because it pertains to the story I'm in
the bulkhead I'm not trying to brag like
hey I got the first seat but it's
pertains to the story it has to be put
in the story okay next to me there's a
lady all right
maybe maybe 40 years old all right now
the plane is packed there's there's not
a seat left in the plane and she boards
the plane she sits down and she's not
not friendly she's not friendly which
we're not talking we're just kind of I
like to keep them myself when I'm on a
plane and I think maybe she does - okay
so about 20 minutes like so five hours
five hours go by you know the [ __ ]
flat it takes for like five hours planes
going is fine everything's great
everything's great and then and then
over the speaker as the plane is you
know we're wrapping up here we're about
to we're about the land we're like any
minute the [ __ ] you know
the stewardess is gonna come on the
intercom and talk to us she does she
says hey guys just so you know we're
laying in we're just our descent into
our descent into our descent into JFK
put your tray tables up in it and I
don't hear the rest of what the
stewardess says because I hear the lady
next to me who's that my seat partner in
the thing it's just me and her right and
she says JFK and she looks at me and I
and I didn't know what to say oh and I
was like uh yeah you know I just said
yeah and she said we're not going to JFK
and I said uh what do you mean and she
said well we're not going to JFK are we
and I said yeah because we're on the
plane and I just died I didn't
understand it then I don't think she's
crazy at this point but I was like I
maybe she just like fell asleep and
she's disoriented or something right so
she's like this can't be right so she so
the now the stewardess is um wrapping up
I can't even remember how happened but
this was like a year and a half ago this
is like way post 9/11 this is like when
[ __ ] is like real tight on airlines okay
so um she says uh she says to the what
he calls tortoise what do you mean we're
going to JFK and the stewardess says um
I well what do you mean that this flight
is from LAX at JFK is no it's not we're
going to Newark did the lady in the seat
so now I'm like oh okay this lady's
crazy and that's fine but she's crazy
and I'm just not going to talk in this
situation because it's not gonna get any
better you're not gonna convince her
she's not crazy
so the the stewardess says um no you
know how they like try to keep it like
not like not like they didn't want to be
like well you're crazy like if I worked
as a stewardess and so he said no go Jo
get [ __ ] crazy we're going we're going
you're out of your [ __ ] mind right so
she says no this flights to JFK and she
says no it's not I'm going we're going
to Newark and and now it's an hour
they're very close to each other so it
doesn't really matter right but the lady
is like freaking out and I'm like you
know how many times in my head
you know me [ __ ] times I checked the
ticket on the on the way to the airport
they like they check at 9 [ __ ] times
so obviously the lady's crazy we're
going to JFK she thought she's going to
Newark for some [ __ ] reason but like
she heard 97 times you checked its
screen where my flight is it delayed no
oh good going to [ __ ] JFK get on you
get on the plane they scan your ticket
seven times and you go there every time
you got to go through a new line you get
a [ __ ] Starbucks in the thing they're
like can I check your ticket though okay
you're going to JFK
here's your macchiato that's what
happens you could barely get out of your
[ __ ] house and get a ride to the
airport without your friends saying can
I see your ticket so we get to the so so
the stewardess says I got a lot to deal
with I'll be right back uh and and so
she she she sits down on her thing and
in and she the stewardesses never land
in the stewardess and the lady's huffin
and puffin she's like do you [ __ ]
believe this I'm like yeah I believe it
I bought the ticket to JFK I don't say
that because I try to not say as much as
I can because she's [ __ ] it's a crazy
and so so um the UH the the the
stewardess is now facing us because
she's in the we're in the bulkhead and
she's facing us in her seat you know how
they sit backwards kind of because
they're that's just how they're set up
so the lady's talking to the girl
face-to-face and she's like she's in the
aisle seat I'm in the window seat and
she's like she's like I don't know how
Airlines could let this happen
I'm on the wrong flight and I'm like
first of all you're crazy you're on the
right flight second of all what do you
mean it's not the airline's fault even
though it kind of is the airline's fault
it's [ __ ] your fault give out you got
on the wrong plane if you got a norm
play even though you didn't because
there's no cuz obviously the seats are
packed the seats are packed you're
telling me there was one empty seat she
got on the wrong plane and just the
coincidence that her seat was like 1b or
whatever or 1a and she sat down on the
only open seat I mean this flight was
this light was jam-packed okay so
there's like no way she's right she's a
crazy person
so she said so the stewardess says well
we when we land and this is why I said
sitting in the front seat was important
because they're having this conversation
right like this right so she says when
we land you know
we'll talk you know and she's [ __ ] so
mad and she gets up
well after we land and she says can I
see your ticket and the lady says yeah
and she pulls out her she goes in her
bag and now I'm like oh [ __ ] great
this is awesome because now the lady
again is we're gonna have proof that
this lady's a [ __ ] lunatic and she
can't make excuses for a [ __ ] plane
ticket it says [ __ ] obviously seat
one 1a 1b at JFK so she pulls out the
[ __ ] ticket and gives it to the
stewardess and the stewardess says how'd
you get on this plane she literally it
wasn't crazy she was on the wrong
[ __ ] plane I'm the only open seat on
the wrong plane and then she landed
wrong and she had to [ __ ] get a hold
right no I don't know but how the [ __ ]
did how does an airline [ __ ] up like
that I don't know what airline I was
probably United pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
heads but I love that she landed in a
wrong city that was great
you remember when the Chicago Airport
had all those fires I was supposed to
land in Chicago I had to get her on oh I
had to get the wrong I had to get to
Toronto and as I was anyway my point is
you never know if someone's [ __ ]
crazy or not you don't know you just
write people off and then your lies
under not crazy but um I left the
airport I was in upstate New York I
didn't get to Toronto but at the flat of
Chicago first there was no direct flight
was so annoying cuz it's like a
five-hour drive if I drove I didn't want
to drive so I drove ice I had to fly to
Cleveland is what I had to fly to knock
Chicago sorry just flying to Cleveland I
fell asleep I wake up and it was like as
our descent into Cleveland yada yada and
I was like what the [ __ ]
Cleveland and I was in the [ __ ]
bulkhead again and I had the
conversation with the stewardess who was
sat down I was like did it say Cleveland
she said yeah I said I thought I was
going to Chicago and she's like oh yeah
Chicago's on fire so we had to get to we
had to get to so we got to Cleveland I
had to fly [ __ ] back to JFK and then
fly to Toronto because there was a
flight because I can go from upstate to
JFK to then we're gonna 20-minute flight
in a 40-minute flight was so annoying
anyway whatever
dude that's there's too many flight
stories but anyway you never know if
someone's [ __ ] insane or not um and
that's it
Here I am going to hit a Toronto back
and I [ __ ] pray to God man it wasn't
raining do it I couldn't do anything it
was lonely as [ __ ] I'm gonna have some
down time I'm looking at Toronto weather
right now uh Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday no rain until
Sunday no rain until Sunday and Monday
all right that'll do I'll be fine
highs of 76 lows of 50 looks like won't
be too [ __ ] but 46 is the lowest that
week um yeah so that's it I hit all the
things I wanted to talk about let me
know your thoughts
oh you know what I'll do I [ __ ]
didn't game the system yet oh wait
bow-wow challenge that's what I wanted
to talk about did you hear about bow ah
this is the best [ __ ] flight
story whatever bow-wow I'll put the
[ __ ] but I'll put the [ __ ] in on
Instagram you put up a picture with of a
private jet and a and a and a like
g-wagen like flight flight day travel
day or whatever and then somebody saw
him after he posted that in coach
flying and people were like it blew up
on Twitter like this [ __ ] front
and you know and I mean I mean how
[ __ ] embarrassing whoa like - dude
you're Bow Wow
you know what I mean your bow wow you're
already people like think you're silly
just what what are you doing Bow Wow had
your name's Bow Wow to you an adult
right it's got travel day and he was in
seat like 36
F and what a stunt and [ __ ] but
not no I mean not stuntin sorry stunting
is actually doing it [ __ ] Bond a
ruins a tall man and then people are on
on on what do you call it and doing the
bow-wow challenge on Twitter and was so
funny it's been so funny people would be
like like something like here's one like
I'm just checking that the hashtags this
like they'll be like bow out challenge
and then they'll have one picture that's
like dope and then they pull out that's
like a wide shot and it's like like
Mother's Day in Palm Springs this guy
writes and it looks like really close
like there's some [ __ ] cool like
trees in the back and then oh there's a
wide shot of it and it's like he could
tell you that I'm Marshalls you know um
it's just so [ __ ] funny that's
somebody like posing like that I got it
I didn't do what I wanted to do one but
I didn't do one [ __ ] bow well um game
is yeah we came the system do it see how
we gain the [ __ ] system check some of
these I'm gonna do like two or three of
these so I'm tired here um latest
all right oh the [ __ ] first one what
do you think about bow-wow trying to be
on a private jet lying about that K read
well just did that
um this is Lance Seabrook oh my god
at your urethra addict 69 ladies and
gentlemen we have the number one change
it of all time hey change it dude your
wreath row addict 69 and his [ __ ]
picture is of him on a horse oh boy
imagine like this guy has parents right
hey dad mom you should get on Twitter
okay I'll follow you what you think
urethra addict 69 really your disowned
that's how that conversation goes um hey
hey Krista Leah have you cried over any
more movies recently he's saying that
because in my last special I talked
about how I cried when I watched the
movie Kazaam I had a bit about that
Kazaam this Shaquille O'Neal movie and
the answer is yeah I do cry at movies
sometimes I cry you know what I cried a
lot our musicals I love musicals and
everyone thinks it's very weird when
they find that out about me because
they're like you [ __ ] don't you
always make fun of everything I'm like I
[ __ ] love musicals I'll give you [ __ ]
man those [ __ ] can sing and
dance and they can do all that [ __ ] and
make you feel stuff and make me prove
that I'm not a robot got a heart it's
great
and whenever music will start every
musical I've ever seen when I start
opening number bawling I don't give a
[ __ ] what it's about it could be
literally something silly like we get
[ __ ] we get [ __ ] we get [ __ ] and I'll
be like because it feels so much emotion
you know so that is what I cry about a
lot and I do cry movies a little bit I
can't remember the movies that I've seen
recently but um what does crystally I
think
comic-con cosplaying Erica Brosnan at E
Brosnan one good good job good job good
job
what does Chris Lee think of comic-con
cosplay I mean it's fine dude but like
if you're going to dress up like a
[ __ ] fairy or like some girl with big
shoulders and a sword yo you make let B
make it be getting paid hourly alright
you're doing it for fun ye u 7um what
what's this
those guys say um yeah do some of these
questions are [ __ ] stupid oh I should
say something
oh my there's a picture here of little
boozy Verte little Aussie needs help
where are his friends this guy tweeted
liquid red at Jung ho sama Jesus Christ
look what he's wearing hip-hop it got
weird man or I should say it's weird how
different hip-hop god that's how I
should that's what I should say um by
the way I [ __ ] never I've listened to
some lil yachty because I made fun of
them a lot there's a new little yachty
song that I I [ __ ] love and I can't
uh I can't front
I [ __ ] love it it's called uh bring it
back and it's weird as [ __ ] and this is
why I like it
because it's not really hip-hop what
little rat little yachty rapping to me
is just like basic but this song I hope
that this is the direction that he goes
it's more of like a Chromeo kind of a
cool vibe kind of like a it makes me
honestly feel like I'm in a car and I'm
16 and I'm driving to pick up a date and
go to [ __ ] prom and then I looked at
the video and the video is him at prom
which is amazing I was like oh that got
really not only
he make me feel that in the song but the
videos about that that's so odd
it's called bring it back I think I'm
trying to look at my iTunes I bought the
[ __ ] thing it's awesome I don't know
if the rest of his songs are like that
or not probably not maybe I don't know
maybe but it's cool but that's what's
talking about like evolving as an artist
like this guy made those basic song
those basic songs the one with him in
the video with him in a baby and in his
face on it I don't know what that song
was but that song wasn't for me I get it
was catchy but this song bring it back
yeah it's [ __ ] cool I don't know it's
different it's cool he's doing something
different never thought I'd say it dude
lil yachty [ __ ] came out with a
banger I think I [ __ ] love this song
everyone hates it led that I say that I
show it too but I think that honestly
they're just saying that because they're
thinking of lil yachties hair dude it's
good and you're a [ __ ] it's good it's
different in it and that's and that's
good and it but it's also good alright
anyway that's it that's all I'm saying
and I wanted to [ __ ] say that because
I wanted you to know that I don't know
why I wanted you to know that but I
wanted you to know that I wanted you to
know that remember to check out blue
apron guys check out this week's menu
and get your first three meals free with
free shipping by the way by going to
blue apron com slash Congrats
alright I have upcoming show dates
coming up I'm going to Austin I'm going
to wet I'm going to West Palm Beach I'm
going to Austin I'm going to wash on
beach I'm going to I don't know Atlantic
City I'm rescheduling Australia guys I
should be doing that by the end of the
year but check it out my dates at
crystally accom slash tour / tour man on
fire June 27th Netflix you guys got to
check that out put it in your queue I
don't know if it's available in your
queue yet but do that download it even I
think you can do that on Netflix now and
by the way we have congratulations shirt
we have a congratulation shirt now up on
the store so a lot of you guys have been
asking for this can we get a podcast
shirt tweet me about hey I want to wear
a podcast shirt to wrap it you guys are
the [ __ ] [ __ ] honestly you babies are
my [ __ ] and you can support this podcast
by going to store
Christel e.com and it's got you know
it's got a lot of cool stuff it's got
some stuff some of the stuff is Mirchi
but some of the stuff is not it's got
its like high-quality it's made in Los
Angeles it's like good [ __ ] it's good
fabric it's really cool I wear it and I
like it it really is good and then tweet
me at congratulations Pot hashtag
congratulations Pot and please don't
forget to rate and review the show
because I'm telling you man if our
numbers don't keep going up I'm done
with this mmm done with this okay so
help me out and do that if you would go
rate review and then check out my store
and then also you can check out the tour
dates and all that you guys are the best
my babies thanks for listening this has
been congratulations the podcast episode
something no clue have a good one
[Music]
[ __ ] you